[Intro music plays]
Host: Welcome to our podcast, where we dive
deep into the world of psychology and explore
the ways in which our minds can influence
our experiences.
Today, we're going to talk about a phenomenon
that affects many people, regardless of their
success or achievements: imposter syndrome.
[Transition music plays]
Host: Imposter syndrome is the experience
of feeling like a fraud or impostor, despite
evidence of your competence or accomplishments.
It's a pervasive and often debilitating feeling
that can affect anyone, from high-achieving
professionals to students and artists.
To better understand imposter syndrome, let's
take a closer look at what it is and how it
can affect us.
Joining us today is Dr. Jane, a psychologist
and expert on imposter syndrome.
Dr. Jane, thank you for joining us today.
Can you start by telling us a little bit more
about what imposter syndrome is, and why it's
so common?
Dr. Jane: Sure.
Imposter syndrome is a psychological phenomenon
where individuals doubt their own abilities
and accomplishments, and have a persistent
fear of being exposed as a fraud or impostor.
It's common because it can affect anyone,
regardless of their background, success, or
achievements.
In fact, research suggests that up to 70%
of people experience imposter syndrome at
some point in their lives.
Host: That's a staggering number.
So, what are some common signs and symptoms
of imposter syndrome?
Dr. Jane: Some common signs of imposter syndrome
include feeling like a fraud, doubting your
own abilities and accomplishments, constantly
seeking validation and reassurance from others,
and downplaying your own achievements.
Individuals with imposter syndrome may also
experience anxiety, self-doubt, and fear of
failure.
Host: And what are some of the underlying
factors that contribute to imposter syndrome?
Dr. Jane: There are several factors that can
contribute to imposter syndrome, including
perfectionism, social comparison, and a lack
of self-confidence.
Perfectionists often set high standards for
themselves and feel like they can never live
up to them, which can contribute to feelings
of inadequacy and self-doubt.
Social comparison, or comparing oneself to
others, can also contribute to imposter syndrome,
as individuals may feel like they don't measure
up to others who they perceive as more successful
or accomplished.
Finally, a lack of self-confidence can make
it difficult to internalize one's own achievements
and accomplishments, which can contribute
to feelings of being a fraud or impostor.
Host: That's really interesting.
So, how can we overcome imposter syndrome
and start to feel more confident in our abilities?
Dr. Jane: There are several strategies that
can be helpful in overcoming imposter syndrome.
One strategy is to practice self-compassion
and be kind to ourselves, rather than beating
ourselves up for perceived failures or shortcomings.
It's also important to recognize and internalize
our own achievements and accomplishments,
rather than downplaying them or attributing
them to luck or other external factors.
Seeking support from others, whether it's
through therapy, coaching, or talking to friends
and family, can also be helpful in overcoming
imposter syndrome.
Host: Those are great tips.
So, let's switch gears a little bit and talk
about imposter syndrome in the workplace.
How can imposter syndrome affect our careers,
and what can we do to overcome it in a professional
setting?
Dr. Jane: Imposter syndrome can have a significant
impact on our careers, as it can lead us to
doubt our abilities and hold ourselves back
from pursuing new opportunities or taking
on new challenges.
In the workplace, it can also contribute to
feelings of burnout and stress, as individuals
may feel like they need to constantly prove
themselves or work harder than others to compensate
for their perceived inadequacies.
Here are some interesting facts about imposter
syndrome:
It affects people from all walks of life:
Imposter syndrome is not limited to any particular
profession or demographic.
It can affect anyone, regardless of their
age, gender, or background.
It's more common than you think: Studies have
shown that up to 70% of people experience
imposter syndrome at some point in their lives.
It's not a mental disorder: While imposter
syndrome can be distressing, it's not considered
a mental disorder.
Rather, it's a common experience that many
people go through.
It can be caused by a variety of factors:
Imposter syndrome can be caused by a number
of factors, including perfectionism, social
comparison, and a lack of self-confidence.
It can lead to burnout: People with imposter
syndrome may feel like they need to constantly
prove themselves or work harder than others,
which can lead to burnout and other negative
outcomes.
It can affect relationships: People with imposter
syndrome may struggle to accept compliments
or may push others away, which can have a
negative impact on their relationships.
It's not always a bad thing: While imposter
syndrome can be distressing, it can also be
a sign that you're pushing yourself out of
your comfort zone and taking on new challenges.
It's important to recognize the positive aspects
of imposter syndrome and use it as motivation
to grow and develop.
Imposter Syndrome personalities
Imposter syndrome can affect individuals from
all personality types and traits.
However, some personality traits may be more
prone to experiencing imposter syndrome than
others.
Here are a few examples:
Perfectionists: People who are perfectionists
often set extremely high standards for themselves
and may struggle with feeling like they haven't
met those expectations.
This can lead to imposter syndrome, as they
feel like they're not good enough or haven't
done enough.
Overachievers: Individuals who are overachievers
may experience imposter syndrome because they
feel like they're not living up to their potential
or that their accomplishments aren't truly
deserved.
This can lead to a cycle of constantly pushing
themselves to achieve more.
Introverts: Introverts may be more likely
to experience imposter syndrome because they
tend to be more introspective and may be more
likely to focus on their own shortcomings
or flaws.
People pleasers: Individuals who are people
pleasers may struggle with imposter syndrome
because they worry about letting others down
or not living up to expectations.
They may also feel like they're not being
true to themselves, which can lead to feelings
of self-doubt.
Highly creative individuals: People who work
in creative fields may experience imposter
syndrome because they often have to put themselves
and their work out there for others to judge.
They may worry that their work isn't good
enough or that they're not as talented as
others in their field.
It's important to note that while certain
personality traits may make someone more susceptible
to imposter syndrome, anyone can experience
it regardless of their personality type.
There have been many famous people who have
openly talked about their struggles with imposter
syndrome.
Here are a few examples:
Maya Angelou: The late poet, author, and civil
rights activist Maya Angelou once said, "I
have written 11 books, but each time I think,
'uh oh, they're going to find out now.
I've run a game on everybody, and they're
going to find me out.'"
Tom Hanks: The Oscar-winning actor Tom Hanks
has spoken publicly about his experience with
imposter syndrome, saying, "No matter what
we've done, there comes a point where you
think, 'How did I get here?
When are they going to discover that I am,
in fact, a fraud and take everything away
from me?'"
Emma Watson: The actress and activist Emma
Watson has also
talked about her struggles with imposter syndrome,
saying, "It's almost like the better I do,
the more my feeling of inadequacy actually
increases."
Michelle Obama: The former First Lady Michelle
Obama has revealed in her memoir "Becoming"
that she has experienced imposter syndrome
throughout her life, saying, "I still have
a little bit of impostor syndrome, it never
goes away, that you're actually listening
to me...It doesn't go away, that feeling that
you shouldn't take me that seriously."
Albert Einstein: The famous physicist Albert
Einstein once wrote in a letter, "The exaggerated
esteem in which my lifework is held makes
me very ill at ease.
I feel compelled to think of myself as an
involuntary swindler."
These examples show that imposter syndrome
can affect anyone, regardless of their level
of success or accomplishments.
It's important to recognize that imposter
syndrome is a common experience and seek support
if needed.